[Music]
ho ho ho Merry Christmas our favorite
giant mon of all time Godzilla has had
quite a few incarnations over the 70 odd
years he has been seen in movies and
shows and in these different movies and
shows there are some evil versions of
him as well as heroic variants as well
some are just playing destructive forces
of nature while quite a few others are
truly Sinister and full of malice so
here in this video we will rank the most
evil incarnations of the top G and also
tell you why let's get to it at number
10 we have the Millennium Godzillas the
Millennium era Godzilla which is in this
reboot of movies is the first to appear
after the original demise in 1954 he has
an anti-hero Persona he somehow appears
to continually Menace Japan over the
years this Godzilla appears
intentionally destructive though but
only targeting Mankind's energy
resources unlike others it hesitates to
retaliate against the military even
enduring assaults without fighting back
until provoked by the full metal missile
launchers showcasing a more measured and
patient personality and hence why he is
so low on this evil list number nine
Shin Godzilla so yeah this Godzilla
appears to be the most evil looking but
is he really evil well he was initially
passive and seemingly unaware of
humanity it remains to be indifferent to
the military's attacks on it until the
American B2 stealth bombers inure it
with the bunker bossing bombs designed
to penetrate heavily armored
fortifications therefore triggering a
furious retaliation with its Atomic
breath in the film's climax though
Gozilla becomes more aggressive
retaliating with the atomic breath and
beam attacks when assaulted by humans so
this Godzilla isn't really evil at all
but only attacks to defend itself and
probably later views Humanity as a
threat to its existence number eight the
H Godzilla awakened 30 years after the
original Godzilla's death by a volcanic
eruption on the Dau Islands in 1984 the
Hy Godzilla diverges from the heroic
Persona of the second generation
Godzilla the showa one which really is a
anti-hero Persona unlike the actively
vengeful 1954 Godzilla this Incarnation
initially appears sympathetic and tragic
navigating human civilization and
causing destruction inadvertently
despite the shift to a more destructive
role in later hay saved movies Godzilla
evolves into an anti-hero in the
Godzilla versus mega God Godzilla 2
movie raising an infant of his species
named Godzilla Jor as well number seven
the second show of Godzilla the second
generation this Godzilla is the most
frequently featured in movies of all
time with Origins dating back to 1955 in
earlier movies like Godzilla rats again
King Kong versus Godzilla and Mothra
versus Godzilla this one emerges as a
destructive force wreaking havoc in
Japan and attacking other monsters
indiscriminately so he can be called
evil in a way however in later movies
like like Gora the three-headed monster
a shift occurs and this gozel begins a
transformation into a more heroic
character reluctantly teaming up with
Mothra and Rodan Godzilla battles the
malevolent space monster King Gora and
defeats it and in subsequent 1960s
movies he is often portrayed as a lesser
of two
evils number six the original Godzilla
the OG the original Godzilla started out
as an oblivious prehistoric sea creature
an amphibious one living deep in the
oceanic depths but this was disrupted
its lifestyle and his habitat was
scorched by the American 1954 hydrogen
bomb tests filled with rage and displac
from its home Godzilla directed his Fury
towards Humanity destroying boats and
eventually wreaking havoc in the city of
Tokyo so he is understandably angry and
is one of the least evil versions since
his taal is actually tragic after
all number five the final was Godzilla
so this is a reboot to even the original
and was unlike the others not a second
generation Godzilla that came out after
the death of the first one awakened by
nuclear testing in 1954 the final wars
Godzilla sought revenge and declared war
on Humanity despite the formation of the
Earth Defense Forces to combat him and
other Kus they were unable to defeat him
the film's narration emphasizes Godzilla
as Humanity's greatest enemy before its
confinement in Antarctica he was all
throughout the movie A vengeful and rage
fill monster against all other kaijus
and humans as well
number four Godzilla Earth he holds the
distinction of being the largest
onscreen incarnation of the character
till date displaying intense aggression
this Godzilla exhibits hostility towards
both humans and other monsters actively
hunting down people fleeing Earth in
2048 even other monsters he is actively
hunting everything considered a Divine
Avenger Godzilla Earth sees itself as a
punishment for Mankind's arrogance and
is determined to ensure Humanity faces
the consequences never allowing them to
escape its WTH but Avenger or not
actively hunting helpless people fleeing
impending doom makes them really evil in
my
books number three space Godzilla this
Kaiju is Godzilla's penultimate enemy in
the Jay series and along with the dester
they are one of the most powerful he is
distinct as being the only
extraterrestrial Godzilla variant in the
movies he is intelligent and displays a
planed combat strategy seeking to
dominate Earth with true males unlike
Godzilla who is dep dicted as a neutral
force a force of nature a destructive
one space Godzilla is portrayed as
intentionally evil with the specific
purpose of defeating Godzilla to render
Earth defenseless for his
domination number two gmk Godzilla
unlike its predecessors this Godzilla
stands out by intentionally targeting
civilians rather than focusing solely on
buildings and the military forces it
exhibits a malevolent nature actively
seeking out the complete destruction of
Japan and its people as a form of
punishment for forgetting the deaths and
atrocities of World War II this marks it
as possibly the first Godzilla to be
Supernatural and also legitimately
considered evil despite earlier
incarnations being antagonistic well
sort of being the only evil one since we
also saw space Godzilla being really
evil as well and number one the most
evil the minus one Godzilla this newest
Godzilla Incarnation is truly evil from
the start even as a godzillasaurus he
attacks the soldiers on Odo without any
prior provocation he seems to hate
Humanity to the core right from the
get-go so after the nuclear testings in
the Pacific in
1946 it mutated him into a Kaiju and his
R was fueled 10 times over and now with
the size and power to destroy anything
in sight this Godzilla heads to Tokyo
and Slaughters as many humans as he can
not even sparing the ships on his path
of Destruction so if you have seen the
movie then you would know he is the most
evil Godzilla variant
ever so we have come to the end of the
video of the most evil Godzillas ever
now if you like this one then check this
other one as well and if you want to
browse for other monster content then
check out our Channel we might have
things that you haven't seen before like
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
one take care fam